قالت هيئه الدفاع عن رئيس حركه النظر راشد
الغنوشي ان المحكمه الابتدائيه قضت بسجنه
لمده عام على خلفيه دعوى تقدم بها احد
عناصر النقابات الامنيه اتهم فيها الغنوشي
بانه وصف رجال الامن بالطواغيت وقد نانت
حركه النهضه الحكم واعتبرته سياسيا بينما
رات فيه اجابات الخلاص دليلا على كيل
التهم الجزافيه والانحراف للسلطه والقانون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
خلفياتها حيثيات الحكم على رئيس حركه
النهضه ورئيس البرلمان السابق بالسجن لمده
عام وما واجهت حجج المنتقدين لهذا الحكم
وفي اي سياق ياتي الحكم بسجن الغنوشي وما
مدى ارتباطه بما شهدته تونس من اعتقالات
سياسيه طالت قيادات في المعارضه بالتزامن
مع انسداد الافق السياسي في البلاد
وما هي الانعكاسات المحتمله لهذا الحكم
على المشهدين السياسي والاجتماعي في تونس
وما فرص قبول اطراف الازمه السياسيه
الراهنه بتغليب لغه الحوار للخروج منها
[موسيقى]
بدون مثوله امام المحكمه اثناء جلسه النطق
بالحكم وفي ظل احتجازه لنحو شهر على ذمه
قضيه اخرى حكمت المحكمه الابتدائيه في
تونس بسجن راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
لمده عام واحد مع غرامه ماليه على خلفيه
ما عرف بملف الطواغيت بحسب هيئه الدفاع
عنه تعود هذه القضيه الى دعوه تقدم بها
احد عناصر النقابات الامنيه وتهم فيها
الغنوشي بانه وصف الامنيين بالطواغيت
اثناء تابينه احد قاده حركه النهضه
حركه النهضه التي قالت ان رئيسها رفض
الموثول امام قضاء يعتبره خاضعا للسلطه
السياسيه لما تبين له التنكيل المتعمد به
هذه الحركه دانت الحكم بسجن الغنوشي ودعت
في بيان الى الافراج الفوريه عنه ووصفت
الحكم الصادره بحقه بانه حكم سياسي ظالم
واضافت الحركه ان راشد الغنوشي معتقل
لتعبيره عن رايه على خلفيه تصريح مزور على
حد وصفها
اما جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه المعارضه فقالت
ان الحكم الصادر بحق راشد الغنوشي يثبت ان
السلطه لم تستطع اثبات اي اعمال ماديه
مجرمه في حقه وان لا احد من المعارضين
مهما كان موقعه او انتمائه في مامن من
مصادره حريته والزجي به في السجن واضافت
الجبهه ان الحكم على الغنوشي وايداع اكثر
من 20 شخصيه سياسيه سجن من دون حجه او
تبرير ليس سوى كيل جزافي للتهم وانحراف
بالسلطه والقانون
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معناه من تونس رياض
الشعيبي المستشار السياسي لرئيسي حركه
النهضه الغنوشي ومن تونس ايضا قيصر الصياح
المحامي والباحث في القانون وابدا معك سيد
قيصر الصياح القضيه الاخيره التي
حكم بها راشد الغنوشي مجرد وصف وهو قد
نفاه مجرد وصف لقوى الامن بانها طواغيت
حكم عليها بالسجن لمده عام وغرامه ماليه
علما انه نفى او بالاحرى فريق الدفاع نفى
هذه لكن هذا يضعنا امام تساؤل ما هذه
التهم وما وجاهت وقوه هذه التهم التي على
اساسها يسجن المعارضون لحكم الرئيس قيس
سعيد
ومقتنع بهذا الحكم انت كمحامي الان بصفتك
المهنيه
هناك محامي بطبيعه الحال ساتحدث بطريقه
قانونيه وساتحدث منطلق عميق جدا في طريقه
تكييف القانونيه للجرائم بصفه عامه بقطع
النظر عن تلك التي حكم فيها الان الاستاذ
راشد الغنوشي او غيره الجرائم لا يمكن لاي
انسان ان يحكم عليها قبل البدء فيها
بابحاث قانونيه يقوم بها ضباط العدليون
المحلفون قانونهم النيابه العموميه ومن
بعد يوم في الصف الثالث القضاه فليعقل او
يتصور ان يكون محامي او حتى قاضي يمكن ان
يحكم بالسجن وحكم عديد القضاه في كافه
البلدان الدنيا بالسجن حتى الوكيل العام
مساعد في تركيا حكم بالسجن و261 معارض في
السجن والقضاء ولا يمكن التشكيك فيه لكن
نقول ان اجيبك بطريقه قانونيه سليمه
باعتبار محامي ان المتهم الذي يحكم كما هو
الحال بالنسبه للسيد راشد الغنوشي غيابيا
لانه رفض الحضور له الحق في الاعتراض ثم
الحق في درجه ثانيه في الاستئناف ثم في
التعقيب ولو الحق حتى في التماس نظر
وتحميل قوانين دوليه واذا كان بريئا يمكن
له حتى ان يدور قضيته لكن لا يمكن باي حال
من الاحوال الجبل خلاص او للمعارضين ان
يستغلوا هذه الفرص لتكييف على اساس ان
نظام ديكتاتوري الطريقه في الانظمه
الديكتاتوريه تكون عموديه
بشكل مباشر لم تجبني بشكل مباشر عن طبيعه
هذه القضيه انما تحدثت بالعموم في المجال
القانوني لكن اسمح لي انتقل هنا الى السيد
رياض الشعيبي كما تبعت القضيه قانونيه
بحته سيد رياض من وجهه نظر السيد قيصر
الصياح ولا يحق لا لجبهه الخلاص ولا لحركه
النهضه ان تضع ما يجري في اطار سياسي
القضيه قضيه قانونيه بحته يمكن
لراشد الغنوشي ان يستانف وربما ايضا ان
يرفع الى اعلى مستوى هذه القضيه لو اراد
القضيه فيها جانب قانوني وفيها جانب سياسي
الجانب القانوني يظهر خاصه في الاخلالات
الاجرائيه الكبيره التي شهدتها هذه القضيه
لعل اهم خلل اجرائي شهدت هذه القضيه انها
الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي يقع محاكمته بالغياب
ورغم طلب الدفاع تاجيل القضيه وتاجيل
النظر فيها الا ان هيئه المحكمه رفضت
التاجيل مما مضطرها هيئه الدفاع لمقاطعه
هذه الجلسه وعدم الحضور وبالتالي الحكم
الذي صدر حكم في غياب المتهم وفي غياب
هيئه الدفاع التي تدافع عن هذا المتهم
وتدفع هذا الجرم وهذا خلل اجراء كبير ايضا
من جهه المضمون ما صرح به الاستاذ راشد
الغنوشي كان في تابين لاحد المتوفين من
المنخرطي حركه النهضه وهذا سياق ديني وقع
استعمال فيه مصطلحات دينيه موجوده في
القران الكريم وموجوده في الثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه وفي تاريخ الثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه
والاستاذ رجل الغنوشي الذي كان طوال 50
سنه من نضاله
وانتاجه الفكري يدين التكفير ويدين
الارهاب ويداف على حريه المعتقد وحريه
الضمير وضد ثقافه الارهاب والتكفير للاسف
اليوم يقع التغاضي على خمسين سنه من قرفه
الفكري والسياسي ويقع توجيه تهمه له مضحكه
لا يمكن ان يصدقها اي احد في العالم كيف
يمكن ان نصدق ان الاستاذ رجل الغنوشي متهم
بالتكفير فهذه تهمه
الابعاد السياسيه لهذه القضيه قبل النقطه
السياسيه نعم سيد
سيد رياض هيئه الدفاع قالت ان كلامه قد
جرى تاويله هو لم يقل او لم يتهم بشكل
مباشر قوات الامن بانها طواغيت لكن بغض
النظر عن يعني
تلك الدقائق القانونيه
البحته الجو العام المتعلق بموقف راشد
الغنوشي من الرئيس قيس سعيد ومن الحكم في
تونس الى اي مدى لعب سياسيا في دفع القضاء
التونسي نحو صدور هذا الحكم بحقه
التدقيق في في المعنى اللغوي والاصطلاحي
للكلمه التي تستعملها للساده الرجل
الغنوشي اصبح امر مفروغ منه
وبالتالي استمرار الحديث في هذا الموضوع
في الحقيقه اصبح من قبيل محاوله التدليل
على ما هو واضح بذاته وبالتالي لا معنى
لذلك ولكن حقيقه الان المناخ السياسي في
البلاد واعتبار القضاء وظيفه بمقتضى
الدستور الجديد وبمقتضى التصريحات الرسميه
الصادره عن السلطه التنفيذيه وراس السلطه
السياسيه في البلاد يجعل الكثير من الامور
تحوم حول قدره القضاء على اقامه العدل
وعلى الفصل في مثل هذه القضايا التي
خلفتها خلفيتها السياسيه اصبحت واضحه
للاسف انا سمعت من ضيفك يتحدث عن السلطه
القضائيه واريد ان اذكره بان راس السلطه
التنفيذيه لا يعتبر ان القضاء سلطه وانما
يعتبرها وظيفه وهذه الوظيفه هي تحت
املاءات السلطه التنفيذيه وتخضع لسياسات
لسياسه الجزائيه للسلطه التنفيذيه
وبالتالي نحن لا نتهم القضاء بعدم
الاستقلاليه وانما ما صرحت به السلطه
التنفيذيه هي التي تنزعت من هذه
الاستقلاليه وهو اهم شرط من شروط اقامه
العدل بالنسبه للسلطه القضائيه والا كيف
يصدر حكم على رئيس حركه النهضه ورئيس
البرلمان في جلسه واحده هي جلسه واحده لم
يحضر فيها المتهم ولم يحظى الدفاع بفرصه
لتقديم حججه وبراهين على تهافت هذه التهمه
لولا ان الحكم كان جاهزا بالمسبق وبالتالي
ما وقع فقط هو اصداره
وابلاغه بل اننا الى حد الان لم نتلقى
اعلاما رسميا بهذا الحكم وما حصل فقط هو
تسريب عبر اروقه المحكمه بطريقه غير
قانونيه
لفحو هذا الحكم وهو تقليد
ذهبت عليه السلطه وانصارها
خلال سنتين الاخيرتين حيث لا يقع الاعلام
رسميا انت تقول ان ما يقع تسريبات بطريقه
او باخرى وهذا خلل ايضا ينتهك حق الدفاع
وينتهك حق الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي اذا انت
تعتبر بان في الامر خللا اجرائيا وان
الامر
يشوبه ما يشوبه من
قضايا سياسيه متعلقه بموقف الرئيس رئيس
البرلمان السابق راشد الغنوشي طيب سيد
قيصر
كيف يمكن فعلا فصل هذه القضيه عن الاطار
السياسي وعن المواقف السياسيه والتجاذبات
السياسيه وهل يمكن فعلا ان يقتنع اي تونسي
بان هذا الامر فقط لمجرد هذه الكلمه التي
يقول فريق الدفاع انه جرى تاويلها املها
علاقه وارتباط
بمواقف سياسيه سابقه طالت اساسا قبل
الغنوشي العديد من القيادات المعارضه
التونسيه
نعم اولا اردت ان اعرج ساجيبك على هذا
السؤال ولكن اردت ان اعرج على ان هناك
مغالطه كبيره لراي العام الدولي والمحلي
الان عندما نقول ان هناك اخليلات زراعيه
وانا السيد لم ياتي وحكمت المحكمه بجلسه
وحيده الى اخره وهذه مغالطه صريحه يعرفها
كافه المحامين والقضاه حتى الذين هم من
خارج تونس باعتبار ماذا باعتبار انني كرجل
قانون اجيب عن هذا باعتبار ان عدم الحضور
في الجلسه الاولى ثم معه بطريقه متلازمه
متزامنه انسحاب هيئه الدفاع يجد رئيس
المحكمه نفسه منفردا ليقرر قرارا نهائيا
اما بالتاخير وهذا يعتبر استهزاء منه على
القضاء وعلى نفسه واما بالحكم وهو ما اتخذ
فيه قرار قاضي القاضي الجالس وصرف القضيه
الى المفاضه ثم قضاء بسجنه صيد الغنوشي
لمده عام تقريبا باعتبار عدم حضوره هذا من
ناحي من الناحيه الثانيه السيد راشد
الغنوشي كان بامكانه وهذا اريد ان اتطور
بالنقاش هنا او في اماكن اخرى لاقول انوس
كان بام الحضور والدفاع عن نفسه جلسه كما
فعل عديد الزعماء في العالم والان راينا
كيف ليس ملك يمثل في الاقفاص حاضر ليجيب
والا سيدان يحكم بالسجن لكن هو رفض عفوا
سيد قيصر لكن يعني هذا الكلام يصح عندما
يكون هناك قناعه اقله لدى المتهم او فريق
الدفاع او ايضا لدى الجهه السياسيه التي
يمثلها ان هذا القضاء مستقل استمعت الى
السيد
رياض وهو يعني يؤكد بان القضاء في تونس قد
اصبح باعتراف السلطه التنفيذيه مجرد وظيفه
وبالتالي ليس هناك تلك القناعه التي تجعل
اي شخص معارض ان يقف امام القضاء ليدافع
عن نفسه ما دام هو يعترف يعرف الحكم مسبقا
ليس دليلا ولا اعفان ولا يعذر المرء بجهل
القانون هاته القواعد الاصوليه انت عندما
تعتبر ان القضاء غير نزيه وغير عدل وان
تهمه ملفقه ما عليك الا ان تدافع على نفسك
بشرف وتكون جنديا امام القضاء وتدافع ولك
الحق في الاعتراض هم الاستئناف ثم التعقيب
وقد تقوم بالرجوع على الدوله وهذا نص
قانوني موجود في تونس اذا ما ظلمتك وحكمت
في حقك بالسجن باطلا ويقضى كذلك برد
اعتبارك بمطلب يقدم لا علينا كل هذا نعرفه
ولهذا السبب قلت لا نريد المغالطه ونحن
نتاسف لكل من يحال على القضاء من مواطنين
ظلما او محامين او قضاه وهذا امر جلل
عندما نرى ان حالات في دول اخرى يحال فيها
اشخاص بلا ذنبا ولا ناقه ولا جمل ويحالونه
الى السجون نعود الى الموضوع لنقول مره
اخيره ان السيد راشد الغنوشي مثله مثل
التونسيين خرج الى وسائل الاعلام في ذات
شهر فبراير وقال منذ ثلاث اشهر ان مشكور
وهو عادل بدليل تراكون لماذا الان التراجع
ونقول الاقامه ظالم ثم اجابه عن سؤالك حتى
اكون في مستوى حجم الاجابه القانونيه كرجل
الدفاع ولسان دفاع قانوني
التهمه التي الفقت التهمه التي وجهت الى
السيد واعتبرها ملفقه هي تومه تتعلق بذكر
الامنيين والقوات المسلحه بانهم توقيت نظر
عن شرحها وتاويله في المعاني والمعجم كلمه
توقيت مجرد الايحاء بها في النص القانوني
ضد القوات المسلحه يؤدي مباشره حسب النص
الى اذلال القوات والى الحق معنوياتها
مسلحه كانت شرطه وامن حرسا او جيشا وهي
جريما يعاقبه للقانون فان هناك حل وحيدا
نفس كل القانون التونسي حتى نرضي هيئه
الدفاع من هنا وهناك لنقول هذه الجريمه
وليس جريمه العموميه ولا يترك القضاء يقول
كلماتها الفاصل في جانب الثالث واخير فيما
يتعلق بها هل يمكن ان نفهم هذه المساله من
زاويه سياسيه مرتبطه بزاويه قانونيه وانا
الان بطريقه عموديه لتوصلت قضاء على وزاره
العدل وزاره العدل تقوم بالايحاء الى قضاه
هذا امر ننفيه مطلقا في تونس ويعتبره
المواطنين موجودا باعتبار ماذا حتى وان
كانت هناك اخلالات على مستوى وزاره العدل
في كافه انحاء الدنيا وراينا الاخلالات
السرقه
وفي كل الاماكن الدنيا فالقضاء التونسي
قضاء مستقلها اجتهاد تونس
والطابعه السياسي له معنى مستقل تماما عن
هذا سيد رياض الشعيبي ما ردك على ما ذكره
السيد قيصر الصياح ان كان لجهه بامكان
راشد الغنوشي ان يدافع عن نفسه بغض النظر
عن نظرته او رؤيته الى هذا القضاء الذي
اعتبره بانه
ليس مسيسا وليس خاضعا للسلطه التنفيذيه ما
ردك
اولا اقامه المقارنات بين ما يحصل في تونس
وما يحصل في الولايات المتحده حقيقه مضحكه
لانه الضمانات
والتجربه الكبيره والخبرات الكبيره التي
تتوفر هناك لا مجال للحديث على مقارنتها
بما يحصل هنا واعتقد انه هذا كما قلت هذه
المقارنه مضحكه ولا داعي للاجابه عنها
اليوم قضيه الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي هي قضيه
سياسيه بامتياز قضيه سياسيه لان الخلفيه
التي حركت الدعوه كانت خلفيه سياسيه هدفها
التنكيل وهدفها التشفي والانتقام من خصم
سياسي الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي كلامه كان
واضح وكما جاء سابقا في اللغه وفي
الاصطلاح المصطلح له معاني واضحه لا داعي
لاعاده الخوض فيها او الاستجال حولها ولكن
الذي حرك هذه القضيه والذي حرك عديد
القضايا واستدعى انه خلال سنتين يقع
محاوله هرسله الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي وجلبه
تحقيق لعشرات المرات كل هذا لا يمكن ان
يكون الا بتوجيه مباشر من السلطه
التنفيذيه وبتدخل مباشر من السلطه
السياسيه في البلاد لا يمكن ان نتخيل ان
كل هذه القضايا تثار ضد الاستاذه رشد
الغنوشي وهو مازال يحمل صفه رئيس البرلمان
على الاقل الى حين الانتخابات الاخيره
وفيما نراه نحن من عدم شرعيه هذا المسار
الى حد الان لا يمكن ان يحصل كل هذا دون
توجيه ودون تدخل سياسي خاصه اننا لا نخمن
فقط ولكن ايضا التصريحات الرسميه الصادره
على اعلى السلطه فالضغط على القضاء وفي
الضغط على القضاه واعتبار ان من يبرهم فهو
متهم مثلهم وهرسلت القضاء والخطابات
المتتاليه التي كان يسمحها كل التونسيين
كلها كانت واضحه في ان هناك ضغط سياسي قوي
على القضاء ومحاوله توجيهه بل ان بعض
القضاه الذين اتخذوا قرارات لا تروق
للسلطه السياسيه في بعض الملفات وقع ووقع
ولا ننسى ان اكثر من خمسين قاضي وقعت وقعت
طردهم واقالتهم من القضاء وفي ذلك تدخل
مباشر واخلالات كبيره باستقلاليه هذه
السلطه انعكاس ذلك الخلفيه
سياسيه
الى ذلك عشرات المعتقلين السياسيين في
قضايا متنوعه الان ومعروضون امام
طيب اذا كان للقضيه خلفيات سياسيه اذا كيف
ستنعكس على المشهد السياسي والاجتماعي
عموما في تونس سيدي رياض برايك
للاسف مثل هذه السياسات ومثل هذه
الاجراءات لا تساعد على خروج البلاد من
الازمه الشامله التي تعيش سواء في المستوى
السياسي او الاقتصادي والاجتماعي الان
السلطه عوض انها تعمل على
توحيد التونسيين وعلى جمعهم حول طاوله
واحده هي طاوله الحوار وعلى البحث على
حلول توافقيه نستطيع من خلالها مواجهه
التحديات والمخاطر الكبيره التي تواجهها
البلاد عوض ان تتوخى هذا المنهج السياسي
الذي تتعاطى معه كل السلطات في كل انحاء
العالم عندما تواجه ازمه بحده الازمه التي
تعيشها تونس للاسف نجد ان هذه السلطه تهرب
الى الامام وتضع راسها في الرمل وتعتقد
بقمحه وتنكيلها بالمعارضين السياسيين
تستطيع ان تفرض
قسط الواقع في حين ان ذلك لا يزيد
الا في الاقتصاديه الحاده
دون اي حل في الافق المستشار السياسي
لرئيس حركه النظر الغنوشه من تونس وشكرا
لقيصر صياح المحامي والبحث في القانون كان
معنا ايضا من تونس
حلقتنا انتهت شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]